whatever you think of Amazon pretty cool
that they made it terminal list is based
of course on a best-selling book by Jack
Carr he's one of the executive producers
he's a former Navy SEAL one of the
best-selling novelists in America one of
the good guys jack Carr thanks so much
for coming on so you must play it must
plea first of all congratulations on the
book The many books this uh show but it
must please you in a way not all viewers
hate it I'm not all critics hate it but
viewers like it much more than critics
how do you feel about that
oh it falls right in line with
everything uh that I understand about
the current culture and climate in
America right now and it seems to have
triggered quite a few of these critics
and I have a couple examples here Daily
Beast titled their review the terminal
list is an unhinged right wing Revenge
fantasy which is on because right left
conservative liberal are not even
mentioned in the show but I think it may
be because the protagonist is competent
with uh weapons and tactics he's strong
he holds those in power accountable and
that could be unsettling for some
particularly some maybe senior members
of the military who have failed upwards
over the last 20 years uh they go on to
write there is some serious danger to
the terminalist pandering to Red State
viewers with routine references to beer
guns country music and hunting uh The
Daily Beast does not like those things
it does not sound like it is much fun
over there but the the 95 percent uh
viewer rating audience rating makes it
all worth it we didn't make it for the
critics we made it for those in the
arena we made it for the soldier of
Sailor Airmen and Marine that went down
range to Iraq and Afghan stand so they
could sit on the couch and say hey these
guys put in the work they put in the
effort to make something special and
make a show that speaks uh speaks to
them and that 95 rating lets me know
that we at least got close and then uh
one more line here it's from TV line it
says The Fugitive meets Seal Team meets
a don't tread on me truck decal we're
served up huge helpings of red meat
masculinity and lots and lots of
American flags they don't like American
flags over there game rant even cites
Revenue Revolutionary War era don't
tread on me flags as a negative so it's
odd that both game Rants and TV line had
to go back to the 1700s to take the side
of the British in their reviews I found
that uh quite telling but uh someone
wrote a horrible review of one of my
latest novel In The Blood and they said
uh something along the lines those what
do you even call a book like this and uh
you call it a number one New York Times
best-selling novel and someone wrote the
same thing about this show and you call
that the number one series on Prime
video and I do want to thank Amazon
because they took a lot of risks with
this show and they took those risks with
us and so my hat is is off to them and
I'm sincerely humbled and grateful Jack
carhou not that long ago was wearing
government-issued clothing carrying a
rifle in weird countries it is just
amazing how successful you have been and
and wonderful wonderful to watch for
real Jack cart thank you for joining us
thanks so much take care
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight